today we're talking about eldon ring's
director reacting to difficulty comments
as well as modders learning how to pause
the game and more
from software's hidetaka miyazaki eldon
rings director has weighed in on a
discussion around the game's difficulty
speaking to the new yorker miyazaki said
he feels apologetic to those who are
hesitant to play from software games due
to their difficulty but maintain that
from software is not planning to change
anything because the feeling of
overcoming hardship is the studio's
quote identity miyazaki continued by
saying the team attempted to purposely
design elden ring so the feeling of
death and rebirth is something that's
enjoyable unlike in real life when you
die and it's game over in other elden
ring news have you noticed you can't
pause the game well one brave modder has
come up with a solution to that problem
there's a catch though while modern
techie w's fix is easy to install and
use in the pc version of elden ring
you'll need to disable easy anti-cheat
to make it run smoothly and give you a
chance to let out all of that mountain
dew you've been chugging during the
middle of a taxing boss fight by
disabling easy anti-cheat though you'll
be forced to play eldon ring in offline
mode and in turn that will disable co-op
invasions and player messages it's a
solution that ultimately suits solo
players so if you're a more social
player you might want to pass on this if
you're curious you can find a link to
the mod as well as instructions on how
to disable easy anti-cheat in the
description
and speaking of mods super lewis 64 has
modded a nintendo switch joy-con and the
ring fit adventure ring con to work in
the game for battling both monsters and
calories super lewis 64 had to actually
jog in his home to make the character
move while squeezing the ring con and
using the motion controls to let his
elden ring character attack as for
healing super lewis had to perform a
squat to recover some health points and
this isn't the first time that super
lewis has used a ring fit controller in
a from software game as he previously
wielded the mighty device in dark souls
3 using a similar setup
but if eldon ring isn't your cup of tea
and you're on xbox then you should get
excited for guardians of the galaxy
coming to game pass on march 10th if you
missed out on it when it first released
last year the game follows marvel's
ragtag group of cosmic mercenaries as
they tangle with dangerous cults and
their own internal strife you can also
look forward to the cloud version of
microsoft flight sim lightning returns
final fantasy 13 kentucky route 0 and
several other games this month meanwhile
over on amazon prime members can scoop
up a free copy of madden 22 for pc until
april 1st now i know from software and
eldon ring difficulty can be a hot topic
so just take it easy in the comment
section alright and i'll see you
tomorrow